So, thank you very much for attending this
talk pip hope you brought your hat for this
talk.
Did you ever wonder why organizations, companies
or even the governments try to when you get
to the Internet and how they are able to do
that even though you don't save the cookies
in your browser.
Your default.
We will cover a little bit about the whole
history of the fingerprint in the web environment
and the browsers.
And towards the end we will talk a little
bit more about more advanced fingerprint techniques.
And also, like how they try to mitigate them.
I say try because it's basically a cat/mouse
game.
And they are in pursuit to circumvent our
fingerprinting protections.
So, it's a game and the user always loses.
And the final thing I'm going to say in the
talk is, I'm going to say the word "Attacker"
a lot.
When I say the word" Attacker," we can think
about anyone who tries to demonize us.
Could be a company, advertiser, anything like
that.
So, that's it.
So, like I said before, I work for the browser.
Mainly work on the mobile stuff.
I work with little bit with the fingerprinting.
If you have questions about the browser, complain,
stop by and ask about it.
So, before I talk about track, we need to
understand what is the motivation?
Like, it's a good word.
If we're talking about the different attacks,
we need to think about the attacker's mentality.
So, we need to know why people want to attack
the user once you demonize the user.
So, star developers, we have a design document.
And we think those are the mainly kind of
goals of the attacker.
The first one is analytics.
So, people to want know organizations want
to know what users do.
How many times a unique user accesses a site?
It's for analytics.
Target ads, personalization.
So, sometimes a company wants to have a hand
wants to send the user a hand crafted experience.
So, it is by doing it, some things make sense.
But we will have having a lot of sense.
For the detection as the organization.
And probably it's the most because they are
made by trying to demonize it.
These are the main goals of attackers.
But before talking about fingerprint techniques
we should understand why the fingerprint techniques
are more and more advanced at this stage.
And one of the motivations is because of the
cookies.
So, I love this.
This quote from the L.A. Times from an article
from 1996 where it says they are data that
can be stored to your PC.
And they access it every time you go back
to the website.
And it says that sites because of the third
party, it was not that clear at that time.
So, again, it was self contained to a single
site.
And the cookies are really simple.
Probably everyone knows here how cookies work.
So, the first step, the user requests a web
page.
They send back the cage with the cookies using
the cookie.
And finally, will the user access a page from
the same website?
So, the server knows things on that page.
It's simple.
It's easy.
But what's happened after the cookie was created
was people were able to attack users.
They were able to attack users.
Especially like advertisers and trackers.
And they did that because cookies are really
easy to [audio cutting out to Skype] and it's
almost the same.
The only difference is the main change, you
have an advertiser.
Normally they're a friend.
So, they have the domain.
The user sends to the website.
The advertiser and their content websites.
The server sends the content to the advertiser.
And the advertiser also sets it up.
But when you go to another website, the advertiser
reads that cookie and they know what kind
of site did you visit.
So, this is a good example created by like
and working with privacy.
Sometimes, for example, we test the news websites.
And later on, you can access health websites.
Search for a curser or something like that.
And now they advertise what you are doing.
So, the third party is attached to this.
But a few people felt lots about that.
For example, and this created a bunch of ad
blockers.
You have privacy badge, and in from EFF, block,
a bunch of ad blockers try to event third
party cookies.
However, what's happened to us, preventing
cookies is not enough anymore.
You need you need to show how the browser
behaves to have really privacy these days.
Because JavaScript, CSS, how HTTP protocol
behaves.
It like exposes the user locality.
Besides the user locality, it exposes the
user's machine.
What kind of machine I am.
It's exposed what language the user navigates
on the Internet.
So, all the tools are amazing, but they are
not enough right now.
If you want to really have privacy, they are
not enough.
So, let's talk a little bit about the browser
fingerprints.
The browser, like I said, we have a document,
a design documentation where we talk about
what kind of fingerprint attacks trackers,
advertisers, governments try on users.
And the four of them are request behavior,
JavaScript attackers, CSS attackers and plugins.
We're to the going to talk about plugins because
if you are using a plugin, you are screwing
up.
Sorry.
So, the first one, the most simple is the
behavior attack.
And basically, it is when you are requesting
content from a server and it's really about
the user agents.
There are others.
But the others are more the HTTP level the
HTTP connection level, people are able to
get the HTTP specification.
This is the simplest one.
A good example is accept language.
So, an attacker or advertiser knows you are
an English speaker if you say language English,
U.S. Or accepting code.
And every browser has a different accept encoding.
So, trackers or malware people, malware attackers,
they know what browser you are on and can
provide you malware specific for you.
And the user agents, so, every time you access
websites, they apply to the machine.
So, it's from the past and we never changed
that.
The other one is, think more about JavaScript.
JavaScript is really interesting because it's
a language that allows you to do anything
and everything.
And in this side, when you do anything and
everything, it's terrible.
So, I don't know if you ever use it the top
browser.
And you can use the secret slides, it can
change how much safe you want.
For example, the default option on JavaScript,
you are able to play video and be able to
play audio.
But when you move up a little bit to the safe
to a more safer privacy.
We start to disable things from the browser.
Start to disable JavaScript, video.
Save audio.
So, the first thing is the navigate objects.
The dot navigate objects.
This object exposes so many things.
Like, for example, this is an example exposed
by language.
Even expose what part am I?
And this shows up and I took it from my Macbook.
It says Mac can tell.
The attacker knows that I'm on a Macbook.
And it's scary.
Really scary.
Especially for, I'm in this, I'm so crazy.
It's really scary.
GS is posting this much information.
Other one is GS other GS information is on
the screen.
So, the problem about the screen is because
when you're mobile or when you are on a notebook,
when you are mobile, especially Android.
Android has so many sometimes you are able
to learn what this specific device does on
the screen.
So, in this example we show like the whole
screen for the Macbook and also the pixel
is scary.
You should never expose that.
So, we tried to mitigate that.
Like make it in a new form.
There's two kind of mitigations.
Researchers explain in the papers.
The first one is make everything in a form.
All the users should have the same values.
It's the approach you use on top browser.
And the other one is make summarize each user
is.
We don't do that because it's a little bit
hard to do that.
To do that without adding issues to the browser.
Because every time you access something, it's
going to make a noise.
And we can make an issue.
So, we make like dates, vendors.
We try to make everything universal.
So, for example, dates.
If you are using your top browser and you
instantiate objects.
And you see the user, and they are all in
the zero.
All of them are each.
We try to normalize them.
All the vendors are the same.
We try to build up the language inside the
browser to normalize everything.
All the fonts in the browser to make it the
same across everywhere.
So, we try to make everything universal.
So, the second one is the web value.
The web value is amazing API.
I remember when I went to release it and the
gamer developers were like insanely excited
about that because they were able to do a
bunch of stuff.
However, since 2016/2015, a few researchers
say how do people play on websites?
The user is able to hear the audio, but it
will be playing in the background.
And it will be used to track users.
But why?
The first thing is the context.
So, every time you create a web browser object
in this group, every time you go to use the
web browser, you must create the context.
The context exposes so much information about
your machine and it is unique.
Even if you have two Macbooks from the same
year and the same day, they are unique.
For instance, this is totally different from
the machine.
Document time is also didn't from machine
to machine.
Nothing is unique.
Like in mention, sometimes they have the two
numbers in the same and other things are the
same across machines.
But objects can expose some information about
the user.
So, we try to normalize a little bit as well.
And there's other this one's the most scary
one.
So, this graph is when I play one single audio.
But these are not able to hear.
I just created audio context and play that.
So, the bluish line is the baseline created
by the experience.
And the red line, red curve, it's my machine.
So, one machine is different from another
machine.
Doesn't matter if you were bought on the same
day in the same place.
It has the psalm configuration.
Each machine is didn't from another machine.
So, when you play this audio, you can see
a difference between them.
So, this block here, this organization is
created using these codes.
This code was in the previous line there is
a paper and this block of code was taken from
the paper.
And this code is really simple.
Create an answer, create and play back.
After that, you get the data, get the frequency.
And the frequency is different for each user.
And even worse, not just each browser, but
each browser version is different.
So, if I play this code, if I don't know.
59, if I do 60, we are talking different values.
So, it is crazy, and fits everything from
the web.
So, it's like it was almost impossible to
make it uniform without breaking the whole
user experience.
And probably it's so simple to explore and
so many people explore that.
It's the time based side channels.
One thing about JavaScript is, like I said
before, the CPU, you can get the same CPU,
the same built into the same date and they
will have few differences.
So, JavaScript is really complex.
JavaScript has an adjustment time, a minimum
agent.
Each is different.
And JavaScript runs on top of the CPU because
of the JavaScript just in time.
Based on that, we are able to know huge function
takes to run and look into that.
So, a good example of that is all those functions
here we were able to calculate the difference
between where a function runs and use the
function to calculate that.
A good example is a block of code that's really
simple.
It's basically so, it was written by Andrew
Bartz in 2007.
The channels are known for like years and
years and years.
And this is an example, basically, they want
to know how long the works in the browser
results when the source is not an image.
For example, in the line nine, if you look
at the line nine, the test of the source and
the damage.
With this code we know how long the browser
the browser sends to the stack and they do
the computations and filters out, okay, this
is not an image.
So, like, it's a really simple code.
And there is we can do kind of things, the
kind of attack
And the thing we do, we try to remove granularity.
We claim 200 milliseconds.
If you get it now and it is attracted by other
performance stuff, the variable will be 100
milliseconds.
It's the best we can do because everyone agrees
side channels, basically the type of channels
are terrible.
And basically, we should remove it from JavaScript.
However, it's not possible to break the whole
web.
So, this is an alternative.
We try to cut the variable.
And it works reasonably.
But, again, it's not a silver bullet.
We know that someone can explore that.
That people are able to explore that.
Like even increase a little bit more of the
timer.
But like for the majority of the attackers,
it works.
The other things that cover today.
And we cover today, because each browser has
a different library.
And each graphics library, even for different
operating systems renders differently.
So, the key for the attack, where there's
a bunch of things on the screen using few
text, few style, few reqs.
And use that to get the data and the image
and sent to a server.
This image is basically a key and a map.
So, we tried a different approach to mitigate
that.
But sadly, it was complex to the user.
We tried to access the HTML files and it shows
a pop up on my screen saying, okay, this user
has tried to go to the image from the browser.
And you're like, you cannot allow, you can
allow.
So, it's for the user, it was the best we
could do we could do about that.
Like that attack.
I think Mozilla's explaining a little bit.
Mozilla is using the same thing a little bit.
But right now, they are kind of following
the same idea as well.
Now talking a little bit about CSS.
With our same property that trackers are able
to fingerprint the line heights.
So, line heights, they are simple, and they
okay.
And the font size.
So, but for different machines, those are
different.
Especially on Firefox.
So, in Firefox, if you get the line height
from if you get the default line height so,
for Linux, it's lines and pixels.
It's 19 dot pixels.
And sometimes it's 19 but what's happening?
It's because fonts are broken.
Fonts are terrible.
And really hard to create a font.
It's really hard to create a font.
And each like each machine each browser, each
assistant has a different default font.
And each font has an official.
So, it is like on Firefox where it uses the
font from the system, the font from the system,
the line height's different.
So, we also try to uniform that.
So, we had the default be instead of the font
size, we need to make sure it's what that
agency recommends so we're following the specification
at least.
But, again, it's not amazing ID.
It should be fixed in the font size instead
of in the fonts.
And from that side instead of browser side.
And talking a little bit more about this.
These are able to track you.
Like the properties.
We have like the best device heights, are
able to strike the device.
The user's machine device size.
So, we also uniform those values.
So, the default puts the 1.0.
We create for the height.
We also make them uniform.
So, when someone tries to know what's the
size of your device, like what's the size
of your device?
We lie to the requester.
And the last thing I didn't talk about is
we do also something about cookies.
And Mozilla called that first by isolation,
what we do.
We are a little bit more fancy.
We have a trademark.
And basically, it is it isolates all the identifier
source.
By what are the source cookies?
Shared work?
Web storage?
For example, when you are accessing a website,
and it has a frame.
In iFrame we isolate inside of iFrame, all
the workers, storage, WebGL.
We try to translate everything for the URL.
The URL is a key to any identified source.
It looks simple.
However, it breaks the whole web when enable
that.
So, it is why Mozilla doesn't have it on by
default.
We need it enabled for isolation.
Programmers, they want to be able to communicate
across the whole domain.
And we don't allow that anymore with the isolation.
Thank you, guys.
[ Applause ]